one your live chip
good evening and welcome to this Central
area planning committee meeting on
Wednesday the 30th of August
2023 I declare the meeting
open my name is counselor John driver
and I am the chair of this committee
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put your hand up to
indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you to speak at the
appropriate time could I ask members to
avoid approaching the top table as this
could create interference with the
cameras and the live stream please note
that the YouTube live stream sound
recording is dependent on the correct
use of the microphones therefore can I
ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn your microphone on and
turn it off when finished please
reference a page or paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers and
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
um
may I have apologies for absence please
cloud
thank you very much uh on to item
three minutes
uh it is recommended the minutes of the
meeting held on the 5th of July 2023
found on pages seven to eight are
approved as a true and accurate record
uh ISO move do I have a second air for
that motion councilor spensely thank you
can we agree by ascent
thank you very much item four
Declarations of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other Regional
interests and non-reachable interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph nine
and appendix B of the code of conduct
for members members are reminded that
they are required also required to
disclose any such interest as soon as
they become aware should the need arise
during the meeting are there any
Declarations of Interest cancer thoughts
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
declare a non-uh bikini interest in that
I know the applicant thank you thank you
have suspensely thank you chair I'd like
to declare a non-pecuniary interest as I
know the applicant as a fellow Trustee
of the Malden Festival thank you thank
you Council Spencer councilor Jennings
thank you chairman I'd like to declare a
non-booking of Interest as I know the
applicant okay thank you very much and
chemist
uh yes thank you chair
um I also know the applicant so uh
similar to other counselors okay thank
you very much Council Shaughnessy
um so on to a gender item five found on
pages 9 to 24.
um
Matthews do you think you could present
the report please
um so this application is for a price
check abuse from class CE osteopath
treatment rooms to a pseudonymous
short-term Holiday Lab accommodation and
this side shows the um location site
better and so this is on on the The High
Street and we've got the High Street
along with the northern Banji and White
Horse Lane
um along the southern boundary
a lot of those have the same time really
this is a block plan which shows the
location of the rooms that are subject
at the application which are adjacent to
the White Horse Lane boundary of the
application sites
and this is the existing first of all
layout showing the um the rooms against
the applications
and this is the proposed layout or the
holiday Labs so one bedroomed
holidays
that's a spot of
the mayor of them the king's head Center
and taken from White Horse Lane so the
application relates to part of the first
floor accommodation and the site is
within the conservation area and King's
Head Center is a grade two listed
building and the current application
follows an appeal being dismissed for
change abuse of the same cloth based
through a residential flat
and also perhaps worth mentioning that
this application was deferred from the
July Central Area committee to provide
the applicant with the opportunity to
provide some more information
um however despite receiving more
information officers still at the view
that the proposal isn't acceptable in
principle and and the amended proposal
along with additional information
submitted and has not fully overcome the
reasons why the previous appeal was
dismissed
have been submitted since
um the previous central air committee it
is not materially different to that
submitted originally and it's still
considered it's not not being
demonstrated that The Proposal complies
with policy E3 which
I.E that it hasn't been demonstrated the
existing business
or service is not and cannot be made
viable benefit marketing as opposed
tables
and there's also the um
the other issue that um no Financial
contribution towards Rams have been made
or secured
despite the applicant hadn't been able
to provided the opportunity to do so
so the process country to the local
development plan and as I said before
hasn't overcome the reasons and the
previous appeal was dismissed and it is
recommended for refusal as set out in
Section 8 or report
thank you Miss Matthews
um
we have public participants for this
planning application in line with the
public participation scheme I now invite
the agent for the application Mr Tim
Farley to speak and may I remind you Mr
Farley that you are allocated two
minutes only for public speaking in
accordance with the scheme
and I hope Mr Farley you will see a
clock
right
okay Mr father can you see the clock
yes I hope you can see that uh so uh
when you're ready you may begin and
we'll start the clock as soon as you
start speaking thank you very much
you may begin Mr Farley
[Music]
demonstrates that the unit has been
suitably marketed in a typical way for a
property on this scale yeah
[Music]
unit the report criticizes marketing the
marketing done for being done are reward
inquiries basis however the report
neglects to highlight about the use of
that disorder was changed in April 2021
more than two years ago as a result of
the changes of medical community use can
operate from any vacant office usage any
any banking of this unit without needing
plan permission because they are both
now class D uses so marketing this unit
for medical use specifically for the
last two years would have been pointless
the the two key policies development for
this decision
E30
medical use that could Now operate from
any vacant office and obviously E5 that
supports the use of the United tourism
as decision makers you're perfectly and
limited to employ a greater weight to
either one of these policies and you
need to be constrained by the other
you convey the policy E5 and bring DNS
into a viable tourism use
um that brings more visitors and
spending to the Town Center or even
favor policy E3 and condemnity units
potentially took two more years of
vacancy and improve this marketing
the international undertaking for the
round of contribution is a way to 10
super adventure
this will be in return to the U.S
exchange Department
as to resolve to approve the application
subject to the receipts of that legal
document
since the years has been vacant for more
than three months you're coming up to
your your nearing your end Mr Farley
Mr Farley
thank you Mr Farley yes I've you just
went over slightly your time I apologize
we had a rather so we we heard you but
it was a bit muffled so apologies for
that I think we got the gist of your
comments
um but thank you very much
um
members I now invite you to put any
questions or make any comments you have
uh on the report
cancel again thank you chair I couldn't
quite catch the bit about the Rams
contributions through the
um if anybody can probably clear was
there was there a sign undertaking in
place for the Rams contribution to be
submitted through you chairman
um the agent um as far as I could he
said that the the legal the Union
National undertaking was with the bank
for signing
um but it's not not finished yet and it
will be submitted as soon as possible
and suggesting that and the council
could approve the application subject to
that that unilateral undertaking being
completed
any other comments
kind of suspensely
catch a polar Spencer I was thank you
chair I was purely going to say that the
Rams contribution could of course be
conditioned I believe
um the other point that I I also did
want to make was that
um reading
um policy one of the ldp and the
possible exceptions to that policy
implementation of that policy I'm not
completely convinced that this doesn't
comply
um although it's not specifically an
employment use it would generate
employment and so I find that rather odd
I also find the idea that
um that this could you know I I think
maybe with regard to the marketing given
all the documents that have been
submitted I do find it rather odd that
we are still just seem to be deciding or
the officers have decided that um
sufficient marketing has not been
carried out I I I don't see that that
would be in the interest of the owner
after so long in any case and certainly
the paperwork that I've read seems to
indicate that that it has so I'm a
little bit puzzled by that but that's
all I want to say at this stage thank
you
councilor Jennings
thank you chair um well I'd like to say
um comes from me being chairman of the
High Street focus group as well
um is that in terms of Tourism it's an
excellent idea to have facilities like
this available on our High Street it is
the center of our town it is the area
that most tourists would want to look at
the um the attractions that we offer in
our High Street secondly I'm doing a
simple Google search today I found that
there are eight osteopaths uh located
within the Malden District within five
miles of my postcode at home
um so the the for the change of use I
can't see that being a major problem at
all as there are eight other osteopaths
available for people within five miles
um
yeah the uh the marketing
um aspect I believe the applicant
marketed the property a very difficult
time considering covid was in
um abundance for a two-year period so
marketing any kind of office unit during
that time and following government
guidelines
Etc I think it would be very difficult
to undertake a sale of any kind of
apartment for working purposes
um
I can't see there being any problem in
accepting this application at all
thank you thank you councilor Jennings
any other comments or views
are we yes cancer yes yes just
um a couple of responses to what's being
said um Ram's contributions can't be
conditioned
um we can have unilateral undertakings
and legal agreements right because it's
a financial contribution we can't put a
condition on in the normal way that no
we will put conditions on requiring
samples of materials or something like
that
um that that's that's quite clear
um you mentioned policy E1 that isn't in
the reasons for refusal account officers
aren't saying that their proposal
contravenes E1 is just E3
um yeah
yeah we talk about E1 in the report but
the reason for refusal is purely is E3
and that's on the basis that that the
the unit the premises is
um a community use and it's not refused
specifically because it wasn't osteopath
yes there may be many other osteopaths
in the in the area but it's it's it's
more looked at more in more general term
than an osteopath or not officers
wouldn't expect an only an osteopath to
be to go back in there it could be any
sort of community use
um which is quite wide um and maybe even
a non-business use but um
[Music]
um
and and just just to clarify
um officers aren't saying that the a
proposed holiday let in the Town Center
wouldn't be a good thing the issue here
is the existing use or the existing
lawful use that will be lost so if that
wasn't an issue officers would be
recommending approval it's the loss of
the existing use not the use that's
proposed
um just just to make sure that that is
clear that officers aren't trying to
downgrade tourism or or
um yeah stop tourism growing in in in
the in the town it's about the loss of
the existing use and that is a policy
requirement
um and that's our starting point and
that's how how the application has been
assessed and yes their property has been
marketed to but
but as it set out in the report the
their offices feel there are failings in
that marketing period and the
information that's being provided and I
mean in trying to be consistent between
applications
um obviously feel that they haven't done
quite enough yet it's possible that they
could do more
um but um in this case they haven't been
hasn't been enough done
um to date but thank you thank you Miss
Matthews uh councilor stilts oh sorry
councilman love
I would like to propose acceptance of
this approval thank you
thank you do we have a second to that
proposal councilor stilts I'll second
that
right Amy
so we put in the Universal
undertaking sorry I'm new to this
you you know later you're an electrical
unilateral undertaking yeah yeah
okay so that's that's the motion then
that it's accepted based on a unilateral
undertaking okay for the Rams so we've
got a proposer uh cancer stilts oh we're
still second that you'll still second
that any other comments people want to
make
no can we have a vote are those in favor
of that motion please
unanimous okay thank you very much
that's carriage
there's any any conditions
um or whether that can be delegated to
offices to agree with the chairman uh I
probably but Council stilts yeah I would
say we delegate the conditions to
officers yeah
yeah thank you it seems uh that seems
sensible yes so so just to clarify it
would be things like
um conditions to make sure it does
actually remain as a holiday let and
doesn't end up being a house because
obviously that's the main reason why
um council is approving it and refused
the application for a house
um and then that that's the main one
that comes to mind that that Pat
wouldn't be applied to other
applications but in this particular case
would be necessary okay thank you Miss
Matthews all right we move then on to
item six found on pages uh 25
.
um it's Matthews can you present a
report for this that relates to the same
overall property though obviously a
different part of the same property
my microphone on this one thank you yeah
thank you
all right
yes so this is the uh
um have you got
um oh actually
um before I start um I have put a
presentation for both applications six
and seven
I don't know whether he wants to
consider them together and I can do them
separately but
um just before then let's yeah let's do
them separately if that's if that's all
right just interested okay so just just
ignore the writing on there for the um
the next item then imagine it's not
there
um
yeah so this is a planning application
for a change of use from offices Class E
and part of an existing flat to a
short-term holiday accommodation which
is super generous and Associated Works
to part of the first floor printing the
High Street including installation of
secondary glazing
so again similar to the previous
presentations about the application site
there with the High Street on the North
to the north and Whitehorse Lane to the
South
this application relates to um rooms
that front onto the High Street so this
is facing north here so the orange area
is the proposed holiday let
foreign
crosshatched the floor space that is
subject to the application and this room
here currently forms part of a flat
um that an existing flat that would be
incorporated into the holiday let if um
plan permission were to be granted
and part of the proposed release for
secondary glazing to be added to the the
um Windows of that in particular the
High Street elevation to in in in
interest of creating a acceptable
quality of life environment for the
occupiers of the holiday let
um
and there's also some other windows that
propose for secondary glazing as well
that's just a photo of the um the front
which all very familiar with I'm sure
um
so
yeah so this this one and this
application differs to the previous
application in that the existing use
um that used to be lost is primarily
office use and not a medical or
Community use so therefore the policies
that apply will be slightly slightly
different so
um E1 is is applicable but E3 isn't in
this case
um
so
um the previous appeals for the change
of use of the same floor space to a
residential flat was dismissed as the
adverse impacts I the loss of the
employment use and the uncertain listed
building and living conditions affects
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits of the provision of
additional residential flat the current
application seeks to address these
concerns with the submission of
additional revised supporting
information
whilst the issue of the loss of
employment has been addressed because
the application is now for a commercial
use rather than a resident purely
residential use it considered a
proposing not acceptable because there
is continuing uncertainty in terms of
the impact on the listed building and
the living conditions and that of within
within the flat and the net and again
the nursing Financial contribution to
all Rams has also still not been secured
or paid
and while some of the inspectors
concerns have been addressed for example
in relation to the installation of
secondary glazing similar similar
concerns to those raised by the sector
still remain as explained in in the
report the application is supported by a
noise survey and assessment which
concludes that such a satisfactory noise
levels within the holiday unit could be
provided subject to soundproofing Works
including secondary glazing air
conditioning units and an internal
acoustic lining but just the lack of
details and certainty that all of these
measures could be installed without
causing harm to the listed building it
cannot be concluded than adequate
quality of life could be provided
see this
um yes so on that basis
um it's recommended the planning
permission is refused
um I did write to the agent
um
a while ago now and certainly before the
um reports were finalized
um setting out a number of questions and
queries and there was certainly
inconsistencies in the application and
trying to seek clarification on this
issue of the noise attenuation measures
that were proposed and requiring details
to be provided so that our conservation
officer could assess fully the impacts
of The Proposal on the listed building
but I've had no response whatsoever so
on that basis I didn't have any choice
but to assess it based on what was
originally submitted and and reached the
conclusions that have been have been
reached but um so the application is
recommended for refusal for the reason
reasons set out in in your agenda thank
you thank you Miss Matthews now
primarily this is about change of use
isn't it for
a gender item six
and seven will be actually the changes
that will be made yeah
um so
um we have again public participation so
Mr if I you have an opportunity uh to
speak uh you have uh two minutes
hopefully the sound will be a little
better than last time I hope
uh so I hope you can see the clock so
when you're ready please begin
yes thank you so the same response with
regards to the internet
will be sent back to you as soon as
possible
and prior to submission we went through
a pre-application consultation with Tim
Hanson the conservation officer and we
encourage that the consultation response
is satisfied with the secondary glazing
the econ station queries are reference
in the noise report to external
insulation I can confirm that the report
discusses internal insulation to the
external walls and they're reported
slightly and
some obviously written but no further
insulation is necessary or proposed
internally or externally to the walls
the noise mitigation is simply the
secondary glazing and the use of air
conditioning for ventilation Mr
Harrison's consultation response also
notes that the location of the proposed
air conditioning units are not shown on
the plans
together
[Music]
don't apologize the air conditioning
units have been set to for about three
years they were there when Mr house and
visitors where these children the
security officer this is about half a
dozen separate running applications over
the last few years
and two separate visits by the brown
inspector the applicant apologizes that
they were installed without a reference
disability consent but would argue that
they could clearly been sensitively
located because nobody has noticed them
however should the conservation officer
wish for them to be relocated and there
are alternative locations for them that
cannot be seen from public viewpoints
the applicant would suggests that
members can follow the office of the
branches of advice from the first
and condition the most mitigation
details which in this case would enroll
the further side of the Zippo
conservation officer and preparation of
a single plan
it would not be expedient to refuse
planning permission just for this
so
dual members attention to the agenda
page 19 where the officer states that
noise mitigation measures can be secured
through the imposition of a condition
um Mr Farley you've you've you've had
your time do you want to just complete
your sentence
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you Mr Farley
um uh fuse councilors
questions
[Laughter]
stunned into silence
well in that case then since nobody has
any counselor stilts yeah I recommend
that we approve this with the conditions
for the
um noise mitigation and also the same as
last time with the unitary or unilateral
yeah
unilateral undertaking
kinda say you you yeah yeah yeah you
know what you mean
okay uh thank you uh councilor still so
we have a proposal do we have a second
uh quite a few councilor Jennings I
think your hand went up first you're
happy to second that uh so uh this is
that we accept this application so this
is the we've got to go through the uh
listed building uh process but as far as
this is concerned then we have a
proposal to accept this and send it by a
by a council still secondly by councilor
Jennings uh uh subject to a unilateral
understanding or undertaking thank you I
will we'll get there eventually okay
um can we have a vote please those in
favor
unanimous okay thank you very much
um and I think in terms of any
conditions let's put these two together
at the end if depending on what how this
next one goes yeah is that yes um if I
was the only thing I'd say is
um perhaps what I said in in response to
the first application was in terms of
making sure it's amazing the holiday
elect those sort of conditions you
wouldn't put on the listed buildings all
I'm suggesting is that since we're
relating to the same flat we sort of you
know put these two together and then
relate those conditions and we'll have a
discussion about that so we move on to
item uh seven then
pay found on pages
41 to 50 and again it's Matthews this
will be quite a similar presentation to
your previous one I'm sure yes I won't
um repeat everything but um I'll just
perhaps just read out the description
which is
um so this is a list of building
application
um seeking consent for Works associated
with the proposed change of use of the
office to a short-term holiday let's
depart the first real friend in the High
Street including installation and
secondary glazing
um
so the main plan I suppose that perhaps
more more
um of interest if you like to the listed
building application than the previous
planning application is the details of
the secondary blazing which was
um one of the main issues um or one of
the issues that apart the previous
appeal and one of the reasons why one of
the reasons why it was refused to see
building consent and these have now come
in so that has gone some way in
addressing the inspector's concerns but
um in the same way as in the same way as
the officers had concerns about the
planning application there's this
inconsistency or the lack of detail
about exactly what noise mitigation
measures were proposed and therefore
unable to fully assess the impact of the
works required
um to the listed building
um but um yeah and therefore there's
just one reason for refusal
um I set out in your agenda papers thank
you
thank you Mr Matthews uh Mr Farley you
have an opportunity again to speak if
you wish to
I don't know
thank you
okay wait so I sorry Mr Farley can we
just sorry Mr father can we just wait
till we get the clock up so if you'd
like to say something then we'll just
need to make sure the clock comes up
um
we're almost there we go so when you're
ready thank you
[Music]
and we will work with the conservation
officer and the financial officer to
provide the necessary details through
the um
as quickly as possible thank you
thank you Mr Farley uh apologies again
right you're the the SoundCloud is not
great but again we I think we got the
gist of your comments so thank you very
much members any uh comments or
questions
thank you
again yeah thank you the
um
State the content of comments by Mr
Hausen
was basically talking about
um the noise mitigation on there but
that seems to have been
um addressed by some of the
mitigations that are being proposed to
be put in then plus the secondary double
glazing
um Miss Matthew says something that's of
interest about where we left on the
previous applications the conditions to
be given to delegated to the officers
this doesn't apply to this there's no
further conditions we can place on this
because it's purely just the fabric of
the building
is that correct
um three chairman
um if Felicity building consent was were
to be granted I there would there would
be conditions that um officers would
recommend be put on
um to try uh I don't they would
needlessly building consent for air
conditioning units for example
um at the moment they're not on the
drawings and we haven't
um there was suggesting that the ones
that that are the setting that they're
already there but there was there might
be able to be moved somewhere better in
terms of impact on this building
um so there would need to be conditions
to control that side of things what the
details about where the air conditioning
units go where there where the
um was there anything else there is
mainly the air conditioning units isn't
it but um yes there would be conditions
like details like that further details
to be submitted that I think officers
recommend
um be imposed if the opportunity arose
thank you thank you Miss Matthews
as I said I didn't know I've never
noticed those and I'm up there most days
to be honest
um so the the same the applicable
conditioning for this not to be a
permanent uh flat to live in it's this
there's a holiday there that's in the
first two applications but it doesn't
apply to this one because it's a
different type of application just for
my learning
yes um to determine um
so that would that would apply to the
planning application so that's the item
six
um but those sort of conditions wouldn't
be applicable for a listed building
consent or the list of building consent
is purely for the physical work to the
building required to carry out the
change of use and not for the change of
use hence the slightly different
descriptions on the two applications
um but um
uh as officers we would be happy for you
to if they would wish to delegate
conditions for both applications and for
us to decide which one which conditions
need to go on which application in in
consultation with the chairman obviously
in the in the usual way
um rather than yeah well that sounds
reasonable well let's see what other
other members feel any other questions
views
Council again I recommended the approval
um based on what Miss Matthews says
regarding the conditions being delegated
to offices okay thank you
um councilor next Bensley uh so second
there so so uh proposal then that this
is accepted by Council wagon seconded by
councilor Nick spensely and we have a
vote please
unanimous okay thank you uh very much
and I think uh
this will be just subject to delegating
conditions to offices that's yes we
would agree the conditions with yourself
chair right okay that's that's fine
that's good thank you very much okay
um on to uh item eight then uh any other
items of business that the chairperson
decides a urgent uh num
name
and therefore
eight
five I'll declare a meeting uh closed
uh thank you for your contributions